CNN broadcasting from its own little
world is fuming that the left and right
in America are living in their own
separate worlds we will examine which
stories matter and why CNN gets it wrong
then what open borders Democrats can
learn from the psychology of lines how
the Muller report could be politically
devastating for President Trump the
universal basic income political schlock
and the end of Twitter I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
so much to get to happy Cyber Monday
we're gonna get into some political
schlock a little bit later
I myself am a best-selling author of
political schlock which is now 40% off
today I believe but before we get to any
of that let's make a little money with
pro talis over 1 million happy pain-free
customers and a 97% success rate
Pro Tallis insults have changed the
footwear industry and created a new
level of expectations never seen before
for comfortable old issues and most
importantly they support our show this
unique patented technology has proven an
incredible 97% effective they offer an
unconditional 90 day love them or your
money back guarantee this is a great
product I love it I got them for sweet
little ELISA they go right in your shoes
custom orthotics can run between four
hundred eight hundred dollars depending
on the variables and what is worse
though is most people stand to benefit
greatly from correcting these common
unknown foot and alignment issues but
most people are completely unaware of
them so right now these products they're
not engineered from a medical or
biomechanical perspective to focus on
alignment a lot of the footwear products
these are a lot of them focus on
aesthetic and fashion or simply on
comfort through cushioning this focuses
on the alignment so the insoles will
focus on the alignment of your ankle all
the way up is somebody who has got
family back pain alignment issues it is
so good highly recommended you can fix
all of that today this Monday and for
the rest of cyber week only my listeners
can get any pro Telus insole for just
4995 at pro talus dot-com when you enter
podcast p OD CA st at checkout that is
the lowest price of the year exclusively
for a loyal customers plus shipping is
free if you buy two or more pairs they
will upgrade you to free expedited
shipping brutalus comm promo code
podcast for any Protel essentials for
just 49.95 plus shipping an incredible
deal for a life-changing insult what do
you have to lose you could feel so much
better do it
so speaking of feeling better i feel a
lot better because I'm not watching CNN
aim anymore but I was watching CNN early
today and brian Stelter is a very very
upset there is a major problem in this
country which problem is a Tundra you
might think immigration right ah no
maybe not you might think the the
economy you might that's a major issue
right fortunately we're getting out of
that slow growth no jobs recovery under
Barack Obama still though we got a
prioritized yeah no not that at all what
is it it's the Sun monstery global
warming brian Stelter take it away I
want you to guess how many times Fox
News mentioned that blockbuster report
on Friday Fox News Alert the White House
releasing a major climate report
concluding that climate change will do
significant damage to the US economy
that was nine of the whole thirty
seconds the Fox News spent covering the
report on Friday let that sink in Fox
only mentioned the report once on
television on Friday what is he talking
about he's talking about the climate
report that came out from the White
House came out from the executive
agencies and there's a worry that
climate change global warming global
cooling whatever is advancing brian
Stelter we'll get to what's in the
report in just one second but brian
Stelter 'he's contention his issue is
not about the report itself it's that
fox news isn't covering the global
warming executive agency report with
wall-to-wall coverage why not well let's
think of some other stories there's a
story that came out about Amanda
Ferguson Weyand a young teacher who was
killed by an illegal alien Joel
Velasquez he was 24 years old he's an
illegal alien it was a hit and run this
guy was out on bond already for an
assault charge he went he killed this
poor girl he didn't even stop he
eventually they caught up with him thank
goodness so let's play that game let's
play the brian Stelter game can we cut
to CNN's coverage of the Amanda Ferguson
Wyant a killing by the illegal alien can
we cut to that coverage no we can
because there's no coverage of it none
whatsoever
so we can play this game all day can't
we brian Stelter because and by the way
which story do you think is more
important the Sun Monster which is going
to kill us all in 2002 or 2007 or 2013
or whenever now
predicting the world is going to end and
it never ends or a real American woman a
real American citizen a young teacher
who was killed by a criminal who was not
supposed to be in this country to begin
with a guy who was in this country
illegally out on bond for an assault
charge killed her and tried to drive
away tried to flee the scene which is a
more relevant story which story speaks
more to people's lives obviously the
story about illegal immigration these
are these are having real effects on
people's lives on the economy on their
jobs on their families on obviously
people who are injured or killed by
illegal aliens that number should be a
zero because none of them are supposed
to be in the country sometimes the left
will come out and say that rates of
criminality among illegal aliens are
lower than for the general population
first of all that statistic is not true
and it's been refuted by a lot of
different studies but you have your
statistics I have my statistics I'm sure
you can find some surveys that show that
that is true the point is it's illegal
immigration illegal immigration is
illegal it's as simple as that the true
number of people who should be injured
or killed by illegal aliens is zero
because not a single one of them is
supposed to be in this country so those
are two issues now what does brian
Stelter make of this as his broader
point what is the actual CNN thesis for
today take it away
the network's pro-trump talk shows are
portraying this as an urgent crisis and
calling it look at the banner here the
battle for the southern border it's a
vivid example of how two Americas are
living side by side we're living in two
different realities supported by two
different news worlds in most of the
country's news media this climate report
is the big story but over on Fox and on
right wing websites it's the caravan
that's a great point brian Stelter is
actually making a perfectly correct
observation it is right now if you look
at the news media have the mainstream
media and then you know I don't know The
Daily wire or maybe Fox News or a couple
newspapers see our TVs they're just a
handful of new media right-wingers it is
true they present different stories that
is media bias what brian Stelter would
prefer is if
we only had one perspective that was
being put out there what he wants is to
return to the good old days when it was
only the left that controlled the news
media it's like two different widths
it's as though different Americans have
different perspectives yes of course
what what creates those two different
worlds in the news media is the
selection of stories and this is by the
way where most of the biases in the
media the trouble with the New York
Times even with CNN frankly is not so
much the caliber of the reporting the
time still has pretty good reporters
even the Washington Post sort of has
good reporters that isn't the issue the
issue is which stories are being run and
which stories are not being run when
Cheryl Atkinson one of the last
journalists in America when she left CBS
it wasn't because they were yelling at
her over something she wrote it wasn't
because of anything like that it was
that the stories were being killed they
were being squashed they wanted to talk
about only stories that were favorable
to the left no stories that rightly
criticized the left or that were
favorable to the right this is what a
worldview is and brian Stelter is right
to people like him to people on CNN to
people at the New York Times this scary
scary Sun monster as drew calls it
global warming global cooling whatever
the hypothetical negative effects of
climate change none of which we are
experiencing right now none of which
have been credibly
and reliably proven to be happening in
any short period of time none of which
have been proven that have been
demonstrated to be caused by human
beings and human efforts they are so
much more concerned and worried about
that that religion of environmentalism
that religion of global warming than
they are about illegal alien criminals
killing Americans at least is honest at
least brian Stelter is honest my
worldview is a worldview that prefers
the real to the theoretical the near to
the far the tangible to the abstract and
so when I see Americans having their
livelihoods
corrupted or ended by a major problem mm
illegal aliens crossing the border every
single day at least well you've got a
whole horde a whole Caravan marching
through threatening to storm across the
border that to me is a greater concern
then the Sun is heating up and the that
the atmosphere is trapping too much heat
in and whatever worry they have today
now why am I not concerned it sounds
like I'm being a little glib when it
comes to global warming the reason I'm
not that concerned is because that's so
so-called scientific consensus which is
nothing more than a political consensus
it's a left-wing politicized activist
consensus has consistently changed its
storyline obviously you see this in the
words initially we had global cooling in
the 1970s that was the great concern
then it turned out the world wasn't
cooling it was warming so we had global
warming through the 1990s and early
2000s and then the world stopped warming
for a long period of time so we got the
unfalsifiable climate change because you
can't disprove climate change we they
have basically heard the UN admit that
that Paris climate Accord deal would not
have done anything to mitigate the
apparent effects of climate change it
would have maybe contained global
warming by two degrees Celsius over the
course of a century the two degrees
Celsius over what the temperature was
before the Industrial Revolution
we're we we have these insinuations from
the left that forests are being
destroyed the California wildfires were
caused by global warming no evidence of
this whatsoever
there's no evidence that it's causing
more wildfires or deforestation we have
more forests today in America than we
did a hundred years ago or two hundred
years ago or three hundred years ago
contrary to the leftist slogan belief to
the global warming alarmists the the
native peoples who were here in America
were not very friendly with the forests
we've done a very good job at conserving
and developing our natural environment
especially since the 1940s where the
size and forests are is way way up how
about rising sea levels or mass
migration any of the
these are the worries that are referred
to in that White House climate report
even that is a little misleading
it's from the executive agencies
released because theoretically they work
under the White House but those
executive agencies aren't staffed
exclusively by Trump appointees the vast
vast majority of the people at those
agencies are lifetime people their
career bureaucrats who have no
particular loyalty to the Trump
administration no similar worldview or
ideological view and so if some of them
are very concerned about global warming
they'll talk about that but what would
regard to the rising sea levels the mass
migration all of that it has simply been
refuted and disputed so many times
they're just remember that movie from Al
Gore we were told the Pacific atolls
those low-lying islands were being
inundated because of global warming
a UK Court ruled that they couldn't play
that in school and that what they did
play the movie in school they would have
to correct that fact because there's no
evidence of that there's no evidence as
a war and the global warming alarmists
claimed that man-made global warming was
shutting down the ocean conveyor in the
Atlantic Ocean there's no evidence of
that at all there's no causal effect
that's been established between carbon
dioxide and warming over the past
650,000 years another claim of An
Inconvenient Truth we were told that the
polar bears are dying to remember that
they were drowning there they're not
going to be able to make it from one ice
float to another one that's also not
true we have more polar bears today many
more polar bears today than we did
decades ago and the the final the big
worry we were promised from Al Gore he
said New York City will be under water
within 10 years or less than 10 years
because of global warming what happened
nothing of the sort I'm in New York
right now I'm hopping through here just
for a hot second on my way down to give
some speeches in Florida Florida we were
told was going to be under water
Florida's not under water either it's
great the only water that I'm seeing in
New York and Florida is in my left is
tears tumblr but none of that happened
they tried they're trying to spin it
they're trying to get out of this all of
these predictions so many of them have
been disproven by time that's the
trouble when you predict the end of the
world is eventually the date that you're
told that's going to happen arrives
when the world doesn't end you look like
a schmuck so he so that that's what
they're telling us to worry about brian
Stelter says you've got to worry about
the global-warming that's gonna sink New
York in Florida and the polar bears and
you say Brian none of that is happening
none of that matters but what about
immigration so well who cares if one
young American woman actually died this
is really what the left thinks I don't
mean to be shallow about this the the
left really believes who cares if one
American woman actually died when
millions of people are hypothetically
dying from global warming who cares that
criminals are pouring across our border
who cares that children have been saved
from human traffickers in coyotes in
that Caravan by Guatemalan and Mexican
authorities before they made it to the
United States who cares about that those
are just a handful of real people but
all the millions who are hypothetically
gonna be those are the ones that they
have to worry about because the left
really cares about humanity but they
don't seem to care much about humans and
they prioritize theory over reality this
issue I'm so glad Ryan Stelter brought
this up because those are two worlds
those are two different worldviews the
difference is the left's worldview is a
fantasy and the rights worldview is
looking around and seeing things as they
are what is actually affecting people
not in the hypothetical century away
future not in the in the imaginary
fantasy world where New York City is
underwater where Florida is underwater
but in reality though that is the
difference between those worldviews and
you don't just have to take my word for
it you can take the word of John Kerry
no less a guy than the former Democrat
nominee for president Secretary of State
under Barack Obama he is wising up and
he realizes that this immigration issue
is posing a huge problem not just for
Democrats in America but for the left
globally here he is we're gonna have
climate refugees look at Europe Europe's
already crushed under this
transformation that's taken place
because of immigration you see that it's
gonna be crushed so he says he's using
the left wing line oh the climate
refugees once all of those islands that
aren't
a flooding flood then they're all gonna
come who knows where to New York and
that'll be flooded too he's he's still
going down that path but then he looks
to Europe and he says but Europe has
been crushed by mass migration he's
actually then using the immigration
issue to underscore his point on global
warming this is the first time that
we're seeing this typically the left
says I'm Pro environment I'm Pro open
borders I'm Pro endless immigration what
John Kerry is saying here is I'm Pro
Environment and I'm gonna try to
convince you to be Pro environment by
pointing out how much more immigration
we're going to have to get if we don't
get Pro environment he's taking an anti
illegal immigration anti open borders
view here this is not just him Hillary
Clinton has said the same thing an
interview I believe with the Guardian
she just said quote I think Europe needs
to get a handle on migration because
that is what lit the flame
I admire the very generous and
compassionate approaches that were taken
particularly by leaders like Angela
Merkel in Germany but I think it is fair
to say Europe has done its part must
send a very clear message we are not
going to be able to continue to provide
refuge and support because if we don't
deal with the immigration issue it will
continue to Royall
the body politic yes it will
took you long enough to realize that
Hillary and the left they don't like
this this immigration thing really
really matters to people not just
conservatives not just Republicans
everybody there was a poll that came out
I think at this point now about a year
ago a little less than a year ago that
showed that even Democrats even when
you're talking about dreamers the kids
who were brought to America before they
were 18 years old and you know they've
known no other country even the most
sympathetic case of illegal aliens the
majority of Democrats did not want to
prioritize giving them amnesty people
really really hate illegal immigration
it's a violation it's an offense to
people it's taking away their Liberty
taking away their national sovereignty
this has become such a major issue
globally not just in the u.s. in Italy
in Germany in Scandinavia that even
Kerry and Hillary Clinton have to
acknowledge this Democrats were trying
during the midterms do you remember they
started running and abolish ice campaign
abolish immigration Customs Enforcement
Alexandria cassia Cortez talked about it
Cynthia Nixon talked about it in New
York Beta Beta Beta O'Rourke talked
about it Robert Francis
he was on the abolish ice kick for a
while and then they they cut that off
because that is a losing campaign issue
among everybody what Democrats could
learn about this issue it's very simple
it comes from the psychology of lines I
mean lines when you're standing on line
you're in a store you're waiting on line
to pay for your food or get your
sandwich or whatever it's called
queueing theory and it's pretty simple
there have been a number of experiments
done by retail stores in the United
States which have found that typical
lines the lines that behind a cashier
behind the counter are relatively
ineffective it's much faster to have a
single line it's actually faster it
reduces wait times for everybody if you
don't just prioritize the people who
have been waiting in line but every so
often you just pick a random person out
of the pack and bring them up and have
them cash out why is that faster because
it discourages people from lining up
days and days in advance it's because if
people think that they're not there's
not going to be a one-to-one correlation
between waiting in line and having
you're making it up to the cashier that
you're not going to wait in line forever
and ever the reason that they don't
institute all of those possible policies
though is because people lose their
minds when you cut them in line people
get very very angry about this they feel
that it is unfair they think that it is
unjust and it is unfair and it is unjust
this is all about people's sense of
justice we all have it
even if we try to deny it sometimes that
is the immigration question some
Democrats and left wingers were confused
they said how is Donald Trump getting so
much support among Hispanic Americans
among immigrants to America you say the
reason he's getting some
port is because those people are legal
immigrants they waited in line online
this is a big debate do you say like a
New Yorker and say online you say like
everyone else was wrong and say in line
the real answer is online but for the
broad audience maybe maybe I'll consider
going between the two do you wait online
or do you try to cut the line go over
the mountains evade law enforcement and
cut everybody off you know legal
immigrants did what they had to do they
paid their money they filled out their
paperwork they they waited they behaved
like good future Americans illegal
aliens do exactly the opposite so it's
no wonder of anybody who would be
irritated at illegal aliens it should be
the legal immigrants who actually did
what they were supposed to do and and
whose immigration regime is being thrown
into question and being threatened by
the thousands and thousands of people
every week I mean two thousand people a
day who cross into our country illegally
so what's to be done with this we have
this Caravan the left tries to deny that
the caravan exists they've tried a few
different lines on this initially they
supported the caravan people Without
Borders they have a right to come in
here open borders then they said the
caravan doesn't exist it's not an issue
at all then they said that the people in
the caravan are women and children and
that they're having teargas fired on
them and it's so awful you've got to
pick a link this is always my advice for
for the left you have to pick a story
and stick with it do you remember last
week when Michael avenatti was arrested
for beating that actress woman and he
said I didn't do it at all but I had a
good excuse it I didn't do it at all but
she hit me first he said no no no mr.
empanada you you can't simultaneously
excuse and deny this action you have to
pick a lane so what is to be done about
this there's been talk about an asylum
deal with Mexico so while these asylum
cases are brought up and all of these
people come to the border they say I'm
here for political asylum I'm escaping
persecution in Honduras or El Salvador
or somewhere and typically in the United
States we let them come into the country
and then we just let them go and we say
okay show up though for your meeting
show up for your appointment in a couple
weeks and then they go and they stay in
the country what President Trump is
trying to work out with Mexico is a deal
that would have these people who have
crossed up from Honduras Guatemala
wherever they're in Mexico have them
stay in Mexico while their Asylum cases
are being heard a couple days ago it was
being reported that this deal has been
struck then yesterday was reported that
the incoming Mexican government has not
reached a deal with the United States so
we actually don't really know where that
deal stands right now and that would be
terrific that would be a good solution
it would again seem just to all of us
that as two thousand people a day pour
into our country we can do anything at
all to stop them and hold them back
because the left in the country is
insisting now that we not even try to
enforce this that we try not not even at
all to enforce the law the the big claim
is that border enforcement fired some
tear gas at people crossing the border
illegally what they forgot to mention is
that Morocco under Barack Obama's
administration Border Patrol agents did
exactly the same thing in 2013 no
outrage no Alyssa Milano tweets know
shocking coverage you know CNN or
whatever they're only upset obviously
because it's happening under a
Republican administration but I got to
tell you it's bad for the country for
all of these people to pour in but the
media focus on this issue is wonderful
for the country it's great for the
country because it shows us in no
uncertain terms that we have to address
this issue and it's a big win for the
GOP and it's a big loser issue for
Democrats Democrats are trying like
brian Stelter to get away from it to
point to anything else they want to
focus on the Moller investigation they
want to focus on Russia collusion they
want to focus on something that at least
for now is is unfalsifiable and that
they can try to spin on the American
people but unfortunately that migrant
caravan is still still down at the
border unfortunately for them you've got
Mexican nationals who are telling these
migrants to go home who are saying Trump
was right that it's an invasion that's
really hard that said we will get some
conclusion at some point from the Muller
investigation
and one of the big headlines right now
is Alan Dershowitz a legendary professor
at Harvard the guy who got OJ off very
sharp legal scholar he has defended
Trump against impeachment and he is now
saying that the Muller report could be
politically devastating to Trump that's
his words so we're getting information
from Paul manna forward we're getting
information perhaps from course he was
already getting information from gates
from Cohen from film that's an awful lot
of people side of the president of
providing evidence it is and I think the
report is going to be devastating to the
President and I know that the
president's team is already working on a
response to the report so could be
politically devastating what does that
mean I don't know this is really
shocking he said it because he seemed to
be something of a trump apologist in
these legal discussions Politico is
predicting this will be a disappointment
this is according to Politico their
sources are defense lawyers for the
president and 15 former government
investigators dating back to the
Watergate saga so John Q Barrett who
worked on iran-contra says that the
report might not even see the light of
day and the way Politico reports that
they say don't get your hopes up don't
you know we might not be able to take
Trump down with this this investigation
the Moller investigation into Trump
collusion is different than iran-contra
this is different than Monica Lewinsky
though both of those occurred under a
law that expired in 1999 it in that that
law that they were working under the
post watergate law required
investigators to tell congress if they
found any impeachable offenses this
investigation is not operating under
those same rubrics so under this rubric
Special Counsel Robert Mulder just has
to tell his boss at DOJ rod Rosenstein
and he'll tell him what he finds the DOJ
that has the discretion on whether or
not to make the report public so they
can make it public they could not make
it public they could make some of it
public they could heavily redact
a lot of aspects of it another sign in
president Trump's favor is that Muller
has been pretty quiet
pretty quiet there have not been a lot
of leaks out of this investigation there
was a lot of political questionable
behavior they hired Peter struck
anti-trump hack at the FBI to work on
the investigation I heard a lot of anti
Trump never Trump people to work on the
investigation but Muller himself doesn't
seem to have been leaking he doesn't
seem to have been underhanded in the
handling of this particular
investigation yet so so we'll see where
that goes the other aspect to remember
is that it takes forever do you remember
the whitewater investigation into
President Clinton happens in the early
90s mid 90s an investigation into what
seemed to be a sweetheart
real estate scheme that the Clintons
were involved in back in Arkansas that
investigation took forever the final
report of that investigation was not
released until 2002 that's two years
after Bill Clinton left office so all in
all I know people are terrified at what
Alan Dershowitz the saying right now
could be politically devastating I'm not
that concerned I'm really not famous
last words I might be speed knock on
wood I might be speaking too soon but it
just seems between the the people who
have worked on these kind of
investigations before to change in law
after 1999 the length of these Muller's
behavior with the press so far and the
fact that it's all up to the DOJ I'm
really skeptical that this is going to
be politically devastating maybe Alan
Dershowitz is trying to light a fire
under the Trump defense right now try to
spur them to come up with a response to
this report but all in all it could be
worse
we had a lot more to talk about we got
to talk about the universal basic income
one of the worst ideas ever we have to
talk about the end of Twitter and
political schlock don't forget that but
first don't miss Andrew clavin's next
chapter of another Kingdom performed by
none other than little old me today
subscribers get exclusive access to
episode 8 titled the darkest hour and
we're coming to the end here I there
aren't that many episodes left if you
haven't seen it binge it go back do it
it's better than at least nine
9.7% of things on Netflix if you're not
a subscriber you won't be able to watch
new episodes of season 2 until Friday so
what are you waiting for you to daily
wire.com subscribe watch the first and
second seasons of another Kingdom
what is the subscription it's 10 bucks a
month for me the Andrew Clavin show at
the bench Bureau show you test questions
in the mailbag you just get a lot of
stuff but you get one thing that is most
important of all and that is the leftist
tears tumblr we're sure I don't have it
on me right now I don't think you're
allowed to get that through TSA I think
in that's regulated like weapons of mass
destruction it's very potent it's the
only vessel it can hold brian Stelter
steers so make sure that you go get it
we'll be right back with a lot more
as people are frivolously spending all
of their money today I do think we
should have a word or two on the
universal basic income have you heard of
this idea the universal basic income has
been kicked around for a few years as a
policy solution to increasing automation
or increasing disparities in the economy
or basically just us getting too rich
and people not having enough jobs not
enough to do it themselves and the idea
is that the government will cut you a
check just cuts just for breathing just
for existing to help supplement your
lifestyle there have been a few
different versions of this right now
Cory Booker and Kamala Harris or both
proposing versions of it so it had been
on the fringes as an idea now it's
coming to the mainstream both of those
guys are running for president in 2020
so Harris actually is proposing a bill
her idea is called the lift act livable
income for families today act get it
it's an acronym I guess a really really
lame acronym like all of them and her
idea is to give families making less
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
up to five hundred dollars per month or
six grand a year in tax credits
individuals making less than 50 grand
would get up to $250 per month in tax
credits from the government this is a
more or less way of significantly giving
a direct transfer to people who are
making decent money 50 grand a hundred
thousand dollars a Charles Marie though
who's a right-winger he's usually lumped
in on the right he also proposed this
idea so it's not just that the left
wingers are saying we need to give
people money directly even some on the
right have embraced it
Charles Murray's his version is a little
bit better because his idea is to
replace the welfare state with the
universal basic income he says look we
spend so much an insane amount of money
on our welfare state it's totally
inefficient and so if we wiped out the
whole of the welfare state apparatus and
just gave people direct transfer
payments that would
be preferable financially and in a in a
moral sense it's so much simpler and
it's so much more honest than our
current highly abuse welfare system
they're both will I hey I like Charles
Marie
I don't like Kamala Harris they're both
wrong the Heritage Foundation said this
very clearly the Jamin owned at the
Heritage Foundation pointed out that
this has been tried before it drives me
crazy when some conservatives get into
this idea because they think well in the
future in the future where the
information economy is going to dominate
the US economy when the jobs that exist
basically just for people who sit and
think all day or who code on computers
or who are only using their minds people
who do not have physical jobs
labor-intensive jobs more traditional
jobs those guys are all gonna be out of
work
never mind by the way that unemployment
virtually does not exist in the United
States right now we have many more jobs
to fill meant people to fill them they
say in the future though that's not
going to happen and we're gonna have so
much money we should just pay the little
people not to bother us so we'll give
them transfer payments and then they
won't argue about you know ten people
controlling all of the world's wealth
this idea has been tried and it's a very
bad idea between 1968 as heritage points
out 1968 in 1980 there were random
controlled trials for the universal
basic income or versions thereof across
six states these particular trials were
testing the negative income tax you know
what a positive income tax is well the
opposite is a negative income tax a
negative income tax guarantees a minimum
income and it phases out as earnings
increase so what happened
they tried virtually the same plan did
people were they happier were they
living more fulfilling productive lives
no they got lazy because that's human
nature we saw in married men a nine
percent drop in hours worked so you
increase their their monthly payments
it's not that they use that money and
reinvest it in something productive or
use that to offset some way to make them
work even more or this event no they
just work ten percent less but actually
those married men were the strongest
workers among them
we saw a drop in hours worked among
married women by 20% we saw a drop in
hours worked among single female heads
of the family by 25% and then we turn to
the single men imagine just take one
little guess what happened to single men
you know guys who are not exactly known
for their accountability or
responsibility you know the unmarried
guys just kind of hanging around we saw
a decrease in hours worked by single men
by 43% nearly half which makes sense
because again we were talking earlier
about the difference between a fantasy
world and the real world
the left's ideological hypothetical
guesses and the conservative acceptance
of the world as it is everyone thinks
you and I both think this that if we got
a check coming in every month for I
don't know $10,000 you know $10,000
check every month
$6,000 who knows and you say oh I would
take that money Oh what I would don't
take that money and I would start 17
different companies and then I would
hire a million people and then I would I
would fly from New York to here to there
and run all of my companies and and be
on the Forbes 500 list but you what
that's not what you would sit on your
couch you would this is what it doesn't
make people more productive it it just
takes that money and men especially
single man would rather work less and
maintain the same quality of life then
take that money and use it to increase
their quality of life because people are
lazy they don't want to work and they
get used to certain lifestyles so I
really this idea is going to
continuously pop up among silly left
wingers and among right-wingers who were
too clever by half who think they
figured out the solution it's a very bad
idea I assume it will go nowhere if cory
booker's is pushing it because cory
booker will never be the president just
not going to happen and but Kamala
Harris is more of a threat I suppose as
a Democrat so we do need to speak and we
got to make sure that the right all gets
on the same page on this because it's a
very bad idea
that will totally undercut work and then
undercuts the dignity of work
working matters and and if you've got
people who are being discouraged from
working by a government program by
engineering social engineering and then
you've set up a system wherein
statistically 100% of your citizenship
is reliant on transfer payments from the
state that is not a culture in which
conservative thought and institutions
are going to thrive not going to happen
it'll be dead we'll all be progressives
within a month a very very bad idea
speaking of bad things for conservatives
twitter is over twitter is totally over
twitter is now banning people for
anything and everything I've been joking
about this I was suspended from Twitter
for making a joke now Twitter is
officially banning people for Mis
gendering now what would you think would
you think misgendering is like when I
read that I thought misgendering was
when you referred to a man as a woman or
a woman as a man
no misgendering is when you refer to a
man who thinks he's a woman ISM as a man
or a woman who thinks that she's a man
as a woman that's misgendering
misgendering according to leftists now
is gender it's accurately gendering
really really bad they I mean the there
we're getting a constant reports about
this the this is officially now the rule
they are going to permanently suspend
people who do this
they're also kicking off conservative
journalists there's a woman named Laura
Loomer who pointed out that the Islamic
culture is not particularly nice to
women or to homosexuals and she was
banned from Twitter for saying that for
making a perfectly true statement Jesse
Kelly a conservative radio host a
conservative pundit was permanently
suspended without any warning just
because we have no idea what he said
there have been some rumors about what
he said but we just don't know and they
won't tell him he has been permanently
suspended it seems to me that Twitter is
over and that's fine Twitter wants to
act as a publisher that's fine we can
regulate them as a publisher who cares
what's going to happen is that we're
going to end up even more in two
different worlds same brian Stelter fear
the left the left always complains about
problems that they've created
and this is one of them brian Stelter is
complaining about two different worlds
well Jack Dorsey at Twitter is doing his
best to bring us to those two different
worlds by kicking off all of the
Conservatives I really I was joking
earlier about who knows the next time
I'll be kicked off Twitter it's only a
matter of time we are on borrowed time
now I don't know what the solution is
there's that website gab which is all
for free speech the reason that some
people haven't gone on there just yet is
it is infested with bigots and and
all-around bad people so obviously so
it's infested with people who had been
kicked off of other social media
platforms or who didn't want to be on
other social media platforms so if they
don't have a lot of more mainstream
voices on there just yet that said if
Twitter is going to start kicking off
and radio hosts if Twitter is going to
start kicking off journalists where else
can we go we're going to make our voice
heard so maybe this means we all have to
set up gab accounts now I don't know
I've said what I haven't started using
it yet but I've set one up and that's
going to be in there for when Twitter
inevitably bans us on cyber monday don't
forget do not forget that you've got to
buy a lot of schlock you've got to buy a
lot of political products there was this
great piece in the New York Post by Kyle
Smith over the weekend called how the
left is profiting from Trump hate they
are pushing all of these stupid products
they're pushing the Pecan resist Ben and
Jerry's ice cream they're pushing a
cashmere sweater that says I miss Barack
it costs three hundred and eighty
dollars they're pushing a shower curtain
for 70 bucks that says support the 25th
amendment the list goes on and on and it
occurred to me I'm a little bit of an
expert when it comes to political
schlock because I did write a
best-selling blank book called reasons
to vote for Democrats so I was wondering
you know instead it's not just the left
that does this the right has political
merchandise well everyone has always had
political merchandise we don't just have
my book we've got Trump II bear we've
got the make America great again hats so
we have our merchandise too but there's
a big difference between the political
schlock on the left and the right
because on the right well all of the
merchandise the prominent merchandise
that I can name in recent memory comes
from place of humor and joy and
exuberance it
from people trying to make a point with
a little sense of humor about it the
blank book or the Trumpy bear or the hat
or whatever on the left all of the
merchandise that I can name comes from a
place of anger emotion frustration I
don't know what point they're making
Kathy Griffin alleged comedian Kathy
Griffin has an entire store a whole line
of products that just say F Trump but
obviously she spells it out two words F
Trump that's the height of create I
don't even know what point she's making
why are they doing this I think in part
it's because they can't really agree on
policy solutions or they're around
candidates all they can really agree on
is that they hate Donald Trump but
they're not witty they're not it's not
coming from a place of wit or humor it's
just so angry and there's a real irony
here I mean the left is constantly
assailing wealth and capitalism we on
the right we love capitalism we love
consumer choice that's why we like the
hats that's why we like the blank books
that's why we like Trump II bear Trumpy
bear is extremely overpriced I'm gonna
buy three of them because why not it's a
funny little product I like it and the
Trump economy is doing very well and
we're all making more money than we were
two years ago and so who cares but but
the right assails wealth creation and
then they start selling $380 cashmere
sweaters that say I miss Barack they
talk about global warming is going to
kill all of us with all of the pollution
is going to destroy the environment then
they produce all this schlock that's
going to end up in the Pacific Ocean by
the metric ton they constantly are
talking about how President Trump should
be courteous and civil and then they put
F Trump on everything that they've got
it's a real irony but but this is what
the left does is it projects and on this
Cyber Monday I hope that they go and buy
all this schlock because the greatest
bit of all is that they're being
defrauded Ben and Jerry's says that
they're going to donate proceeds from
their pecan resist ice cream to liberal
causes they're gonna donate $100,000
they make half a billion dollars worth
of ice cream per year they're gonna
donate a pittance nothing a penny off
the street and the left is doing it and
that's great because it means that all
the left is gonna do is make rich
millionaire capitalists even richer go
for it guys happy Cyber Monday
so I'm gonna be down in Florida if
you're in Tallahassee comes to me
tomorrow be giving a speech and in the
meantime I will see you on the show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018